this video is about an experiment I've
wanted to do for years and the
unexpected result I got when I did
it have you ever had a simple question
ruin your life of course you have right
like it's perfectly normal to spend
months and months doing nothing else but
obsessing over a question that no one
else cares about like does light
actually slow down in water I know you
probably think the answer is obvious
like definitely slows down like we
learned that in high school but I've
never really believed it like it just
seems odd in Einstein's the of
Relativity the speed of light is this
super fundamental thing like no matter
where you are in the universe or what
speed you're going at you will always
find light to be traveling at the speed
SE except in a glass of water I mean how
can that actually be true I stopped
worrying about it for a while because I
thought there was no way to find out the
answer until recently when I realized
that there is a way to accurately time
how long it takes for light to travel
using something called lighter and
insanely that technology just happens to
be in my phone yeah seriously this bit
of the phone that I managed to smash
recently that thing measures the time it
takes for light to bounce off an object
and come back my phone uses that
incredible technology just to improve
the focus in photos a little bit insane
so of course I tried to do this
experiment
okay it's angry no surface detected come
on this is ridiculous H yeah so that
didn't work this time but eventually I
did get it to work and it gave me the
answer it was just understanding that
answer that took months off my life the
issue is that common explanations for
why light slows down in water are wrong
and even The Uncommon explanations for
why light slows down are also wrong so
maybe light doesn't actually slow down
at all incredibly that's exactly what
one of my favorite textbooks says we'll
get to that but first let's deal with
these let's start with some explanations
for why light slows down that are so
common you've probably heard them in
school but they're completely wrong I
think the most common one and the one
that I believed for a while goes like
this you have this light and when it
travels between water molecules it's
still going at the regular speed C but
what happens is when it bumps into a
molecule it gets absorbed by that
molecule for a little while and then
later on released and then absorbed
again and released and this adds enough
time lag to the whole process that the
particle has slowed down light does
sometimes get absorbed by molecules but
we can tell that this explanation is
wrong because when light does get
absorbed what happens is it doesn't
remember where it came from and it gets
reemitted in any random Direction and so
if we let it get reemitted in random
directions then that means that overall
the light doesn't go in a straight line
from A to B but every bit of light
spreads out into all kinds of directions
and so when you look at light in water
you should expect that instead of going
in a straight line it spreads out that's
not what we see and so that can't be the
right explanation another reason you can
tell this is false is because molecules
only want to absorb certain frequencies
of light that means only specific colors
of light would get absorbed and then
reemitted so everything else should
still travel at the speed C but that's
not what supposedly happens every type
of light gets slowed down by water
there's another common explanation that
goes wrong for exactly the same kind of
reasons and this one says that what
happens is the light travels at the
speed C between molecules but it knocks
into the molecules and Ricochet around
which means that its path ends up being
a lot longer than it would have been you
can see that this has the same floor it
would mean that light should completely
spread out but that's not what we see
one thing to note about both of those
wrong explanations is they involve
thinking of light as a little particle
like this which I can tell you is almost
always the wrong way to think about
light like yes in some specific
circumstances light acts like a particle
but not this kind of particle and so I
think that this is really an unhelpful
way to think about light and instead in
this video we're going to talk about
light as a wave which I'll explain later
but anyway going back to those
explanations if those two other
explanations are wrong then what are
some other common explanations that seem
like they're more correct there was this
other one that kept coming up and it was
about secondary waves in the videos I'd
seen they'd usually make three claims
the first two turned out to be correct
and super important to the actual answer
and the third turned out to be wildly
misleading here they are when you shine
light into water what happens is that
the original light just actually goes
through the water completely unaffected
but the electrons inside of the water do
get affected by the Light and because of
the light they emit their own waves when
you add up the original light plus all
of the light coming from the electrons
you supposedly get light that's
traveling slower yeah when I started
this I didn't understand the first thing
about that explanation and to get it I
had to go right back and figure out like
what light even is for that I turned to
my two favorite textbooks the fan
lectures in physics and matter and
interactions and in the process I
learned so much that I wish I knew about
light earlier we usually use the letter
c to represent the speed of light but
I'd argue it shouldn't be called that it
should be called the maximum speed of
causality or even better how quickly one
thing can affect another for example
imagine this is the Sun and this is the
earth the earth is being held in its
orbit around the Sun by its attraction
to the sun you might have heard though
that if the sun was to suddenly
disappear then Earth wouldn't
immediately be flung out into space
instead it'll take about 8 minutes and
then it will be flung out into space why
is that it's because the message that
the sun has disappeared can only travel
at a particular speed which is the speed
C that is the quickest that one thing
can affect another C is actually the
maximum speed in the universe because if
there was an object that could travel
faster than sea then you could use it to
set send messages faster than C and
that's not allowed I used to think it
was kind of a coincidence that the speed
of light was equal to the maximum speed
of causality like maybe it was just
because light was a massless particle or
something like that but actually there's
a really good reason for it and it makes
a lot of sense when you look at this
next example let's say I have these two
electrons and this electron feels a
force because of this one but say I
picked up this one and I accelerated it
would this electron immediately know
about this electron's new position and
update the force that it feels no right
because it needs to wait until the
message from that particle arrives to it
but what's actually delivering that
message this is the key part light is
the messenger whenever a charge particle
accelerates it sends the message far and
wide at the speed C using light but when
I realized what kind of message light
sends that's when I felt like I really
understood light for the first time
light's whole purpose is to harass
charge particles imagine that I push
this electron up and down then the light
that it makes is going to be shaped like
this here's what that means for the
other electron that gets into the path
of that light if the light gets up to
here then this is supposed to be an
arrow representing how strongly the
electron is going to get punched upwards
and then as the light travels it punches
it up even more strongly upwards and
then as it passes here it starts to
punch it downwards and upwards again and
then downwards the net result is that as
this light passes this electron is
pushed up and down basically light is a
packet of electrical forces traveling
through space incidentally this answers
a question that used to really bother me
if light is a wave then what's waving
we're used to thinking about waves as
something like water waves where there's
a physical medium that's slushing about
but that's not the type of wave that
light is light is just a wavering of how
strong the electromagnetic force is at
any point in space you can see that at
this point in space right now the
electric force points upwards but a
little bit later it will Point even
further up and then later it will Point
down and that that's what light is it's
this field strength changing over time
here I've represented it with these
poorly made arrows because I think
that's evocative of like these forces
and how they change over time but
usually the way you represent light is
with this wave and you can see that it
represents the exact same thing this um
wave is just capturing how strong the
forces are at every Point um but it's
just joint up so it looks a little bit
nicer
and so you'll see these pictures of like
light as a wave traveling through space
but it's the same thing the thing that's
waving is the strength of the magnetic
force not any medium back to our poor
electron we know that as this light
passes it it will oscillate up and down
but we know exactly what happens to
oscillating charged particles they're
accelerating so they're making light the
light that this electron makes is
actually exactly the same as the light
that originally hit it except it's in
the opposite direction and usually it's
a bit weaker but what's the effect of
these two bits of light combined well
let's look at it from the perspective of
another electron that's further down the
line is it going to experience two
separate pieces of light well actually
no because remember light is just a
bunch of electric forces so when this
piece of light tries to push this
electron downwards
this piece of light is going to be
trying to push it upwards but a little
bit more weakly you can see that that
happens everywhere when this one pushes
up the other one pushes down but a
little bit weakly and so it's like this
one slightly negates the effect of this
one it's actually a really similar
effect to how active noise cancelling
works so when the headphones detect a
particular wave of sound they make their
own sound which is in the opposite
direction the crazy thing is when you
add these two pieces of sound you get
much less sound and that's what this
electron is doing as well when it gets
hit with light it hits back with its own
light that partially negates the
original so that was my mini crash
course in light and now we can just use
those ingredients to figure out whether
that explanation about why light slows
down in water actually makes any sense
remember the first bit was that this
light enters the water and is completely
unaffected by the the water and goes
right through so far we know that that
bit is correct and then it says that the
electrons that are inside of this water
then react by making their own light
which makes sense because remember as
this light goes through it makes all of
these electrons jiggle up and down and
jiggling electrons make light and it is
true that each of these electrons
responds by making their own light when
you add the original light with the
light from all of these electrons you
would expect something interesting to
happen I mean we've already seen that
when waves add up they can do
interesting things like cancel out but
the YouTube videos in particular would
use these animations to try and explain
how when you add this piece of light
that's traveling at the speed C with
these other pieces of light that are all
also traveling at the speed C you get
some light that isn't traveling at the
speed speed C this is the original light
and this is what the light from the
electrons looks like and you can see
that they're moving at the same speed
because they don't move relative to each
other in other words they always keep in
time with each other now let me just add
them together and the result is this
other light that does move relative to
the original pieces of light and so it
must have a different speed to the other
two when I saw these animations I
couldn't understand how they were
working but I felt that I had to accept
it because they'd shown me proof but
here's the insane thing when I was
making this video I finally tried to
just replicate their little
demonstration just to see for myself and
like to understand it so I did it
exactly the way that they said they've
done it and they do not work here we got
the original light and the electron
light which is in a similar form
and then we're just going to add them
together and look they don't move
relative to each other I was so mad when
I realized that these things are just
straight up lies you can't add two
pieces of light that are going at the
speed C and expect to get light that's
going slower it just doesn't work
mathematically and they usually mention
the difference between phase velocity
and group velocity at this point to try
and explain how this could work but that
just muddies the water I had to go and
try and understand what those two things
mean and now I know that that phenomena
is only relevant if you already have
waves that are going at different speeds
so what the hell you won't believe this
but as I was trying to make this
animation for you I realized what was
going wrong and it's actually kind of
ridiculous and I can't even be mad about
it basically I think that they
accidentally left off a set of brackets
here is this electron wave and it's
supposed to be traveling at the same
speed see which it is right now but if I
accidentally forgot about this set of
brackets now even though the wave looks
like it's the same it's actually not
it's traveling at a different speed and
so now the two waves are not traveling
at the same speed C and so of course
when you add them they're not going to
travel at the speed C either and you can
see that's what happens it's slightly
annoying but I think this was just an
honest mistake after I realized that
these videos don't work
I turned to textbooks that I trusted and
they seem to point to another
possibility maybe light doesn't slow
down at all the Fineman lectures on this
Topic start off with a kind of cryptic
statement that seems to suggest light
doesn't really slow down it says it is
approximately true that light does
appear to slow down but all
contributions of the field are traveling
at the ultimate velocity C so in other
words the original light is traveling at
the speed C and so are all the other
pieces of light but maybe when you add
them all up they just appear to be
traveling slower I don't know the
statement was a little bit cryptic so I
wasn't 100% sure what it meant but on
the other hand my other favorite
textbook was completely unequivocal it
put it very bluntly it asks you to
imagine this experiment your friend aims
a laser at your location precisely at
time T1 and turns on the laser you
record the time T2 at which you detect
the light knowing the distance between
your locations you can calculate the
speed in this case it will still give 3
* 10 8
m/s even though there's water in the way
or to put it another way if you measure
the speed of light in water using the
most sensible method which is to take
the distance of this container and then
just dividing it by the time that it
takes for light to get from one side to
the other you get that the speed of
light in water is actually just equal to
C in other words light doesn't actually
slow down in
water this is a very testable prediction
and so I tried to test it for this I'm
going to use the lighter in my phone and
the fact that it pulses light and it
measures how long it takes for that
light to get
back all right so I'm about to dunk my
phone
in and right now before it's in the
water it's saying that there's about 30
cm to the other
side that's um way outside of the range
that I
measured I want to clear up one thing
about this measurement because it's
quite confusing so the thing that my
phone can measure is actually time
specifically the amount of time that it
takes to go from one side of the
container get reflected and come back
but it tells you that what it's
measuring is the distance how is that
possible well it uses the fact that
distance is equal to the speed times the
time taken so the time taken is the
thing that it actually measured but it
cheats because it assumes that the speed
of light is always C and since C is a
well-known constant it can use that
value and the time taken that it
measured to give you a distance and that
hack should work most of the time unless
you happen to be doing this experiment
underwater and the speed of light in
water really is slower than C so
supposedly light is supposed to slow
down to about 3/4 of its original speed
when it's in water which is a huge
slowdown which will absolutely mess up
this distance measurement because this
distance is measured using C as the
speed when it should be C * 3/4 if you
know the actual distance here and you
compare it to what your phone says if it
says that the new distance is longer
that's because it wasn't correctly
accounting for the fact that light slows
down in water but if you did this
experiment and you found that the
distance is actually the real distance
then that means that the time taken
hasn't actually changed which means that
the speed is exactly the same as well so
that means that if the phone measures
the distance correctly the speed of
light in water is actually not reduced
it's still equal to C and that was
exactly what I was expecting to
find reading doesn't even make sense
outside of water
nice this was a recurring theme the
phone readings disagreed with the actual
distances even when there was no water a
fatal floor in my plan perhaps but I
pushed on
anyway okay whatever so if I double tap
on the
screen oh no it just actually says it
okay this is perfect all right so let's
put this
in Come on talk to me this was also a
recurring theme every time I tried to
put the phone in water it refused to
believe that there was a surface worth
detecting okay I'm back um I think this
is going to work here I've got this
container that is 9 1/2 cm tall what I'm
going to do is I'm going to set my phone
on top of it but then this time um I'm
going to pour some uh water in and see
how the measurement changes as we go and
like if the speed of light is the same
whether we're in water or not in water
then distance shouldn't change cuz the
time that it takes for light to go from
the top to the bottom should be exactly
the same how clever it says that the
height of this is actually 11 cm which
is a bit different from what I measured
but doesn't matter it does
matter oh please work please work why is
it suddenly not detecting anything surf
detected now surf detected
yeah that didn't work and it didn't work
the next four times either even though I
hadn't yet done the experiment I was
pretty sure about what the results were
going to be because of this very simple
argument imagine we have this light
coming from this light source if there
was no water in the way we know that
this would travel through at the speed C
but even if there is water there we know
that the original light will travel
through unimpeded so it's still
traveling at the speed C the only
difference is that there's now a second
source of light every time this original
light gets to a particular layer the
electrons in that layer are going to get
oscillated by that light and they are
going to produce their own light which
I'm going to represent like this because
it's some complicated thing that comes
from adding all of the light from all of
the electrons in that layer but it's
some sort of light here now in terms of
timing there's one very crucial fact and
that is there's no time lag between the
time that this light enters this Slayer
and this these electrons start jiggling
and produce their own light and that's
because electrons produce their own
light as soon as they feel any
acceleration so the moment that this
nonzero Force hits this electron it will
start oscillating and it will produce
light and so there's no time lag at all
that means that whenever this light gets
to a new layer immediately there'll be
some light from those electrons but
remember when we're talking about the
speed of light in water what we're
interested in is not the original light
or the light coming from the electrons
but the sum of those two lights again we
don't know what it is but it's going to
be some complicated thing the question
though is how fast does this overall
light travel through the water and in
particular we want to know does it keep
up with the original light going at the
speed C or does it go slower here's my
argument for why it has to keep going at
the same speed as the original light
remember the moment that this light gets
to this layer it will immediately
produce some light from the electrons
which will then sum immediately to some
resulting light and so the resulting
light has also reached the same layer in
the same
time these three bits of Light have kept
in time with each other which means that
this resulting light must have been
traveling at the same speed as the
original so they're both traveling at
the speed C so there you go light really
doesn't slow down in water but then why
do you get the effects as if light slows
down in water like the wav length of
light decreasing and like the light
bending when it hits water well the fan
lectures explain how you get those
effects from first principles and Grant
from 3 blue 1 Brown has made a very
beautiful video explaining that whole
proof so I highly recommend that you
watch that so I'm not going to go over
that proof here but I do want to give
you the very basic gists of it and it
all comes down to the fact that you
can't send messages faster than the
speed of light imagine our light now
goes through a thin slice of water we
know that what actually happens is that
the original light just keeps going
through that material at the speed C and
doesn't care at all but the electrons
inside of that material are disturbed by
the passage of light and they start
oscillating there's one important thing
that I haven't yet told you about the
light coming from these electrons so far
I've been representing it as if the
light from this electron only goes in
the forward Direction but that's not
actually true each of these electrons
starts to radiate in many different
directions however it most strongly
radiates forwards and backwards but it
does radiate in the other directions as
well now why does this matter well you
might have thought that if you had an
electron here it would only be affected
by the original light and light coming
from the electron directly in front of
it but that's not true actually it does
receive some light from all of the other
electrons the reason why that's so
critical is this the electron that's
right in front of it is the shortest
distance away but this electron for
example is much further and remember
that nothing travels faster than the
speed of light so even though all of
these are actually bouncing in unison
with each other it's not going to look
like that from the perspective of this
electron because it takes some time for
every message to be delivered right and
the further away the longer that that
mess message is going to take because
messages can only travel at the speed C
imagine that these two are bouncing in
unison and this particular bounce makes
this first little peak of
light so far these bits of light are in
unison with each other but now let's
consider the bit that's going to arrive
at this
electron here I've got to turn this
one
by the time this one has arrived they're
actually pretty out of sync with each
other this peak that used to be in time
with that Peak is now actually in time
with this trough and so these two
partially cancel each other
out in fact if you add up the light from
all of the previous electrons on an
electron that's in the next layer of the
water then what you get is all these
bits of light that are actually quite
out of syn with each other even though
the electrons really were bouncing in
unison from this electron's point of
view they're not in unison when this
electron looks at one of the further
away electrons it's looking at what that
electron was doing back in time it's
actually the exact same effect that
explains why when you look at very
distant objects in the night sky you're
actually seeing how they were in the
past it's the fact that the electron's
light is out of date when it gets to the
next layer that overall gives the
impression that all of the light is
lagging behind I read and reread
fineman's chapter on the refractive
index for ages but I remember the day
when it all finally clicked I was so
happy because it felt like I just
understood something very fundamental I
remember how happy I was so clearly
because genuinely the next day this
happened
hi I'm panicking right
now one of my friends suggested that I
try out this thing called chat GPT he
was saying that like you know it's
really good at answering questions
especially like factual questions and so
I should give it a go and I wanted to
ask a physics question so I just asked
um does light slow down in water it said
yes followed by a bunch of nonsense and
I said arrogantly I don't think so has
there been any experiments to prove this
and the answer he gave
me has me really panicked yes there have
been many experiments that have shown
that light slows down when it passes
through water in particular it mentioned
an experiment done by hyans using a
telescope but that's ridiculous because
there's not exactly a bunch of water
between here and the moon I pointed that
out and it did concede but it said that
many many many other people had done
this experiment and it was so confident
that I started to get worried
I don't know what to believe I guess I
mean I did all this math and I thought
that that was um definitive and then now
some AI is telling me that uh I'm
completely wrong and that people have
actually done this experiment that I uh
about to do and they got a different
result from what I expected you can't
make this stuff up so anyway
um
so yeah I I decided that I had to just
do this experiment myself and I wanted
to do it in a way that would 100%
convinced me that it was the right
result um and I wouldn't be second
guessing it afterwards so I decided that
I'm going to buy a proper laser meter
from the hardware store I'm in the car
right now because it's pouring and I'm
just waiting it out so yeah uh you want
to buy that and hopefully that will give
me the right results
let's see I got the laser meter and now
what I'm going to do is that same
experiment again I'm going to test how
um far this meter thinks uh the distance
is from the top of the drug to the
bottom and I'm going to do it um once
without water and once with
water okay gives me
11.2 CM if the old distance is is like
11 cm then the new distance should be
approximately something around
14.5 okay so if the result is like
approximately 11 cm then that means that
the speed of light in water is about the
same whereas if it's about 4 14.5 then
um it means that the speed is
significantly slower so let's
see
okay a for about the same spot
and
okay I think that's a positive
result
so I've been thinking about maybe
whether this doesn't work the way that I
think it does so it turns out there are
two types of lighter um there is one
that's called phase based lighter and if
you use that sort of lighter um it
should give you a smaller speed of light
because it's just based on the phase and
we know that the phase is delayed there
is a possibility that this is a
phase-based lighter um I think I think
that's unlikely but it might be why I'm
getting the wrong result or like what
seems like it should be the wrong result
but there is another type of lighter and
that's called time oflight lighter and
it does exactly what you'd expect it
pulses light very very quickly and then
that light comes um hits an object and
bounces back and it measures the time
difference between when the the light
was sent and when it arrives back so I
want to make sure that what I use is a
time of flight later because that should
give me the result that light travels at
the same speed no matter what medium
it's in and I was a bit skeptical about
whether the lighter in here would be
time of flight because it seems like
such an impossible task you know you
have to be pulsing these lasers
incredibly fast and then not only that
when it comes back you have to be able
to very accurately and quickly measure
the light and how long it took and these
are very very short time scales that
we're talking about like you know the
time that it takes light to go from the
top of this jug of water to the bottom
is almost nothing um but it turns out
the lighter in here really is a time of
flight lighter uh it uses some really
cool technology I was reading the
patterns for it and yeah it's kind of
amazing um it actually has a single
Photon Avalanche detector in it which uh
I really want one of those so yeah this
is the real deal and let's do the
experiment again and see if we get the
same result it turns out that a part of
what I was doing wrong last time was
that I had the phone way too close to
the water and at such short distances so
I'd say like less than 20 cm it's really
bad but the phone seems quite good once
you have distances of about 30 cm so
here I've got this saying that this
distance from here to the table is about
31 CM but if I instead use
this um I get a distance
of yeah
30.6 so very similar so these two ways
of measuring the speed of light agree
for now when there's no water in the way
but let's see what happens when I move
the
water and now it's saying that this
distance is
33 six or
so let's see if this
agrees
whoa look at
this
33.9 so they
agree so I I really am
wrong okay in the next video I
investigated why light actually slows
down but before you watch that I'd
highly recommend the video on three blue
one brown on this
topic